ينضم إلي الآن المحلل العسكري لشبكة CNN
اللفتنانت جنرال مارك هيرتلينج وهو
أيضًا القائد العام السابق
للجيش الأمريكي في أوروبا والجيش السابع،
يسعدني تواجدك معنا
ويسعدني أن أكون معك
روزماري،
لذلك أريد أن أبدأ بالحصول على رسالتك
التقييم العسكري للهجوم
المضاد لأوكرانيا وأين تسير الأمور
الآن لأن
وزير دفاع البلاد قال لشبكة CNN يوم الاثنين إن
الهجوم المضاد متأخر عن الجدول الزمني ولكن
يسير وفقًا للخطة، هل توافق
على هذا التقييم؟
أفعل روزماري هذا كان صعبًا
أه  عملية هجومية ضد
مواقع دفاعية معززة للغاية وملغومة
كان لدى الروس أشهر لوضعها موضع التنفيذ
بكل صدق قبل
بدء الهجوم قبل بضعة أسابيع، كنت قلقًا
بشأن مدى صعوبة
استمرار الأوكرانيين في المناورة
ضد بعض هذه
المواقع الدفاعية.  تم تعزيزها من قبل الروس، لذا
نعم، إنها تسير بشكل أبطأ بكثير، إنها
المرة الأولى التي يحاول فيها الأوكرانيون القيام
بشيء على هذه
العملية الهجومية واسعة النطاق باستخدام معدات جديدة
حصلوا عليها مؤخرًا، لذلك
اعتقدت نوعًا ما أن الأمر قد يستغرق بعض
الوقت  أبطأ مما كان متوقعًا ولكنه
يسير على طول الطرق التي
يتطلعون إلى تحقيقها وأه مع التوجه
نحو الأهداف الرئيسية التي
كانت دائمًا جزءًا من الحملة